Speaker 1: I just absolutely love this story
I'm starting with today.
Colorado election officials are formally ordering
a recount in Lauren Boebert congressional
race, which she won by five 550 votes against
challenger Adam Fresh.
Now, if you look at the reporting, they say
very clearly this is not expected to change
the result.
But this is so fascinating because these people
on the right who just insist everything's
stolen, recount everything, audit everything,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Now, there is actually a legitimate reason
for a recount to be ordered in a race that
Lauren Boebert is, of course, extraordinarily
relieved to have survived because she almost
went down after just one term in Congress
to Adam French.
So there's an article from the Colorado Sun
and it says Colorado elections officials formally
order recount in race between Lauren Boebert
and Adam Frisch.
Boebert leads fresh, who has already conceded
by 550 votes.
The recount is not expected to change the
outcome of the third congressional district
race.
This is a mandatory recount and it was expected
this was a closely watched race.
Boebert leads fresh.
The margin is 550, but the law is that you
must have a mandatory recount when the number
of votes separating the two leading candidates
is less than half of a percentage point of
the number of votes cast, the margin is 0.3%,
meaning that the recount must take place.
The secretary of State, Janet Griswald, who's
a Democrat, added the results of the District
three race reinforce the fact that every vote
matters.
Colorado voters have made their voices heard.
I'm ordering the recount in accordance with
Colorado law.
This can begin immediately.
Recounts rarely shift the major margin beyond
a few votes, which is why Fresh conceded in
the closer than expected contest.
The third district leans heavily in Republicans
favor.
This is this is just great.
So I don't think it will change the outcome.
I believe Lauren Boebert really won.
This is still a fascinating race because as
the article points out, that third district
in Colorado is quite a right leaning district.
And the fact that it came down to 0.3 between
an incumbent Republican member of Congress,
Lauren Boebert, and the challenger Adam Frisch,
means that MAGA really isn't safe.
And we saw Madison Cawthorn defeated and removed
from the House of Representatives.
We'll talk about him in the next segment and
his crazy outgoing speech.
But there is a real question as to the viability
of MAGA going into 2024 and just making Lauren
Boebert have to wait a little bit longer is
a really great thing that I can certainly
get behind.
Now, when it comes to 2024, we still don't
know what is going to be the level of strength
of these MAGA candidates.
I think it will be different if Donald Trump
remains in the race and becomes the nominee
versus if Trump remains in the race but loses
the nomination, versus if Donald Trump simply
bails on the primaries because it's looking
so terribly.
We don't know which of those three scenarios
ultimately will happen.
But if it's the ones that are not so good
for Trump, this may be it for these MAGA people.
We will be years removed from MAGA in November
of 2024 and it would be great if people like
Boebert were removed and ended up being just
sort of a blip in American political history.
Cawthorn was removed, Marjorie Taylor GREENE
won easily.
Lauren Boebert won, but by a very small margin.
Let's hope it keeps going in that direction.
And listen, maybe the recount will find that
actually Adam Frisch won, but not expected
to.
And I don't believe that that will be the
case